こんにちははじめ社長ですはい私今ここ
はずめ社長の4系のお家の4階にいるん
ですけれどもこのお家を買って積み出して
から約2年が経ちましたいろんな場所を
リフォームしたりこうサウナを作ったりと
か照明が暗すぎるので全部新しくしたりと
か屋上にテラス作ったりとかいろんなこと
をしてきた中どんどん新しいものを作っ
てくだけじゃなくてあの美化活動掃除とか
片付けとかそういうのもすごい大事なん
ですよあのね俺超でかい家にせんで分かり
ました家とかねお部屋っていうのはね
大きければいいってものではない大和症を
兼ねると言いますが家に限っては兼ねませ
んあのね掃除とか本当にもう絶対1人だと
無理そもそも1人でも1Kのお部屋すらも
掃除できませんそんなこともないですけど
それは怠けすぎでした到底1人で掃除
できる規模ではないんですよ全てがなので
定期的に家政府も来ていただいております
掃除してもらってますスタフとがみんなで
掃除してこの4億件の落を綺麗に保とうと
日々掃除してるわけなんですけれどもあの
間に合わどう考えてもスペースが広すぎる
物が多すぎる規模がでかすぎて掃除が
間に合いませんはい引っ越します嘘です
引っ越しはしないんですけども本当にね
無理なのよこの王子の全てを掃除すること
が限りなく不可能なので2年間住んできて
僕気づいたんですよある場所だけがずっと
掃除されずにとんでもない汚れ方をして
いるそれを一目につくというお客さんとか
来たりとかこうなんかオレンジの近所の人
とか見た時に絶対これ気づくなっていう
ところがくそ汚れててちょっと気になり
ましたので今回それのあのお掃除していき
たいと思いますマジ汚いんですよ汚すぎて
逆に気づかないみたいなところありません
人の心とかで早速その汚れている場所を今
から行っていきたいと思いますでは行き
ましょうはいというわけで4銀のうの表庭
に来ましたもう見えてるんじゃない
でしょうかえこの家で特に汚い
ところ外壁ですはい要件のうちですね結構
高い壁にこう囲まれてるんですよ進撃の
巨人みたいにまるでウォールマリア違うん
ですなんか壁に囲まれてるんですけれども
結構汚れがすごいんですよこれ見てもらっ
て分かるか
なでなんか外にさらされてない元々こう
いう色だったんですよこれギリギリ天井が
あるかないかみたいなこっちは天井あるの
でなんか汚れずに綺麗にこういう色になっ
てるんですけどもこんだけ汚れちゃったん
でしょうねやばいのよめっちゃ汚れてて僕
の家ですね表庭と裏庭あるんですけども
ここが表庭で同じような感じで裏庭も汚れ
てますで壁っていうのはね内側と外側が
ありまして外側もめちゃくちゃ汚れてます
正面来ましたはいあここはまだ綺麗だな
ここは比較的綺麗なんですけどここ
ねここからめっちゃ黒くないですか
なんかここら
辺これ多分ね汚れ落ちると思うの
よ落ちなかったらどうしようまその時は
その時考えますけどもうなんか黒くなっ
ちゃっててこういうところとかこういうの
ちょっと綺麗にできないかなと思ってます
こことかね
ほら元々絶対白いのよこことかもすごい
ですねめちゃくちゃ汚れてますねなんかさ
見てちょっと汚れ落ちてるのよこれ何
かって言うと多分海沿いで風が強くてこ
ッパーがなんかこうやって動いてなんか
ワイパーみたいな植物自然のワイパーで
こんだけ汚れ落ちてるのでこれ確実に綺麗
にできますというわけで綺麗にするために
すごいもの用意しました今回4億円の外壁
の汚れを落とすために業務用の高圧水場
洗浄なんでしょう今回業務用の高圧洗浄機
準備しましたいや皆さんあれですよあの
市販で売ってるような小洗浄機なんか車と
か汚れを落とすようなああいうやつとは
レベルが違うこれガソリンで国らしくて
めちゃくちゃオが強いらしいので今回この
業務用の高圧水蒸機を使って4億円の家の
最も汚いところ壁を掃除していきたいと
思いますでは
行こうでは付けていき
ますえなん
でこれでいいの
かちなみにこれ家庭用の高圧水蒸機ある
じゃないですか
あれの78倍かな78倍の威力で結構ね
普通になんか掃除とかじゃないレベルの
威力らしいんです行ってみていいですか
きますね
はいなんかやばくない
やばい試しに床のレガでやってみます行き
ます
うわ見てやばい
汚れがミルミル落ち
ます見てこのレガだけピッカピカになっ
[音楽]
たやば
これいやすごいなここでやめたくねえで
早速壁掃除していきたいと思い
ます
なんかめっちゃ白くなってないなって
ますほら
[音楽]
めっちゃやばい
なんかやばいレベルの汚れが落ちてる気が
するすごいすごいけどやっぱ0距離とかで
やんないとだねそうですね0強でやると見
てくださいこれもうなんか汚れがほぼ落ち
ますねちょっと頑張ってやっていき
[音楽]
ます
これ時間かかる
な見てやばくないうわすごいめっちゃ取れ
てるこれちょっと離れてってみる
と落ちないんですよめっちゃ近づいてやん
ないと落ちないぐらい汚れが強力です販の
高圧水機だと
無理はいというわけで今ババと圧機でて
おりますいや気持ちいいよね見ててこう
いうのはもう汚れがどんどん落ちてって
こうなんか汚いものが綺麗になってくのっ
てめっちゃ見てて気持ちいいなと思って
動画にしてみましたみなどう心現れ
てる辺も来てるよねはいきついこれ腕
きつくねいやめっちゃきつい
す終わらせる
ぞこはもう折り返しまできましたねいや俺
AB型で機帳面なところと機帳面じゃない
ところがあってなんかこういう壁みたいな
やつはやり始めると全部綺麗にしたくなり
ますうわあ穴なんか穴開いちゃってねえ
開いてたっけこれ元から
いや今開けたかもしんないいす今穴行った
よな多分
はい近すぎも良くないなはいもう少しです
あと右上のそこら辺かないやもう本当水圧
が熱い水圧が強いからなんか水が細くて
めちゃくちゃ細いペンで細いマジックとか
こうシャーペンで塗りつぶしてる気分あと
真ん中
のそこでもう今日は終わろうあのね結構
時間かかってますよこれこの1パネル壁の
この1パネルでかなり時間かかってます
これ大丈夫終わる大丈夫えもどこが汚れ
てるかわかんないんだけど本当にさああと
はもうちょっとした汚れを綺麗に落として
いくだけで完璧に綺麗な壁になりますさあ
完成はどうなるのか
[音楽]
もう夕方はいというわけで1パネル終わり
ましたでも見
てすごくない色の違い今ですねこの一面
だけ洗ったんですけどももう別のタイル
みたいな色がもう全く違ってますねこれ
あのふざけでピピピッてやっちゃったやつ
で上見たら見てくださいもうここから違う
とそしてこうです
いや
すご元々こんな色捨てたのね全然違うんす
も色がただ今濡れてるからまだちょっと色
が濃いですけども乾いたらもっと色の変化
が出そう
えここ一面で30分かかりまし
た今日はここ
までどうも久しぶりです1個だ終わりそう
になかったので最強のス洗浄金2個借り
ましたこれでちょっと2倍の速度でやって
いきたいと思うんですけれども前回綺麗に
したところ乾いたんですけど見て
ください1面だけ超綺麗すごくね色のさ別
の素材みたいになってますただ前回思った
のがこれ一面綺麗にするだけでもめっちゃ
時間がかかったので今日からはいろんな
場所を綺麗にしていきたいと思いますま壁
も大事なんだけど例えばこれ家の中の壁
でしょ家の外のこういうねここの壁とかも
綺麗にしていきたいし前回やっててね
やっぱレンガとかめっちゃ汚れてるのよ
こことかめっちゃ綺麗にしてみたいと思う
ので見て
ください見えるかな分かるでしょ前回
ちょっとだけやったらもう色が全然違って
てこことかやばくないこの色の違いこれ
やる前とやった後で全然違うんですよなの
で壁だけとも言わずちょっといろんな場所
を綺麗にしていきたいと思います水圧洗浄
下もレンダの時間があるのでなるべく
頑張っていろんなとこ綺麗にしたいと思い
ますでは行きましょうというわけで早速
レンガのところやっていきたいと思います
行き
[音楽]
ますやばいもんもう別の色だもんそこだけ
は2とり威力本当すごいんですよ
もうおらというで2つ使って綺麗にして
いきたいと思い
ますこれなかやばく
ないえま見
[音楽]
て
やばいもう違う家次ちょっと床やっていき
たいと思います床もねもう見てやった後
すごくない回当ててみ
[音楽]
ます
ご覧くださいもう別なのよ色がこれすごい
なちょっとなるべく床も綺麗にしていき
たいと思いますはいどうでしょうレガは
めっちゃ綺麗になったけど床見てこんな
真っ黒だった床がもう別の床の色になっ
てるんですよこれはねもうやってても
とっても気持ちよかったですでこう汚れが
溜まっていくので水で定期的に流したりし
てえ汚れを流していきますでさらに細かく
やっていき
ましょうはいというわけでレガのこの部分
を終わりましたご覧
[音楽]
くださいどうですか皆さんこの差もう一目
瞭然でしょ4億円のお家ができた時はこう
いう色だったんだろうなでこのレガだけ
じゃなくて床もめっちゃ綺麗になりました
一応分かりやすくここら辺でやめてるん
ですけどももう見
てこれ影じゃないですからね影じゃなく
この汚れの
差もういかに水圧洗浄機がやばいかが
分かりますすごいはいというわけでいかが
でしょうかすごい綺麗になりましたこれ
やっと今1/4ぐらい終わったんですけど
もまだちょっとあるんですけども
[音楽]
え誰かにらしますちょこれだけで動画
終わるのもったいないんでこの先はあの
第一ありにやらせようと思いますさあ頼ん
だこれかレガはこれだけ綺麗にな
るってことが分かったので次はちょっと家
の外の外壁を綺麗にしていきたいと思い
ます行きましょうじゃあ次はちょっと家の
外の壁綺麗にしていきたいと思います
なんかこことかもめっちゃ黒ずんでるんだ
ねこういうところ壁の外側で他の人から見
られるところなんですよここが汚いと
なんか家が汚れてるみたいに思われそうな
のでめっちゃ大事な場所だと思いますきれ
にしていきたいと思いますではやっていき
ますどれぐらい汚れが取れるのでしょう
か
やばいやばい取れるこれやばい全部やら
なきゃこれ
[音楽]
やばいちゃんとやりますあんまり汚れて
ないとったらめ出た
なねマジでやばいぞこれ火くれるどころか
3ヶ月は硬い
ぞやばい
よ
待って絶対取れてよね
今まいっ
[音楽]
かつうわもうやばいすえちょっとやったら
崩れますよ
やばい
えっと壊れてますねこれどうするまずちょ
壊れそうじゃ
ない待ってもう壊れてんじゃんあれやばい
絶対これのせいだよねはい
家壊れたあの水圧が強すぎて家の壁が壊れ
ましたこれまずいですかなりちょっと今で
もめちゃ中途幅なんで綺麗にできるとこ
だけとりあえず綺麗にします落下すると
危ないのでちょっととりあえず落として
おき
[音楽]
ますくっついてて取れないわこれかと言っ
て戻しもでき
ない
あなんか取れたり
[音楽]
ます
どうだいいやちょっとマジで時間かかるな
汚れが深すぎて高圧浄を出力最大にして
ピンポイントで当てないと汚れが落ちませ
んめっちゃ時間かかりますはいちょっと壁
が壊れるほどの威力で怖いんですけども
とりあえずここだけは自分でやりたいと
思いますやり
ます
うきっつせるぞこの戦いに収縮を
打つ
[拍手]
はいというわけで1時間半ぐらい経ち
ました無事にこのここのゾーン全部綺麗に
することができました
全然色違うんですよ全部綺麗だと元の色が
分かんないと思うんですけどももう
めっちゃ白くなったのよこれこう見え
て汚れがかなり落ちてますねもう本当に
綺麗になってるんのよこれあこれ分かり
やすいですねえっと色の比較としては
こんな感じの色の差です
ねここの色の差これぐらい変わりました
本当はここまなりたいんですけどもここは
え誰かにやらせますはい1個やりたい場所
がありましてなんかガレージオレンジの
ガレージちょっと白いんですけどもなんか
めっちゃこういう黒い謎のよがあるんで
これちょっと落ちるのかやってみたいと
思いますこれで落ちたら結構嬉しいけどな
行き
ます落ちるんだ落ちるんだこれじゃあ
[音楽]
やろう
きつどうも3日目です昨日も日が落ちそう
だったのでちょっと今日朝からまた続き
やっていこうと思いますとりあえずこれ
だけ絶対
落とすガレージですねこの黒いのなんか何
なんだろうなやっぱ雨水とかかなちょっと
でもこれめっちゃ気に食わなかったんで
ここは綺麗にしたいと思います頑張り
ます大体綺麗になりましたちょっとねめ雑
なんですけどもめちゃくちゃ黒いところ
だけは綺麗にできましたズームしたら
分かると思うんです
けど結構雑なんですよねここ本当に汚れを
落ちなくてもちょっともう大変だったので
え誰かにやらしますま形は完成してます
もう1箇所やりたいんですよ次はこの階段
なんかね階段ってかるというかなんか緑色
なりがちじゃないですか分かるかなこう
いうのこここういうやつねこういう感じで
なんか階段もねなんか緑がかるというか
やっぱ汚くなっちゃうんですよねあこう
いうところとかねこういうのこういうの
こういうのこういうのやだやだやだこう
いうのねこの階段周りちょっと綺麗にし
たいと思います行きますよしちょっと売っ
てみ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ますあ落ちるねある程度落ちるねこと
か
めっちゃ
落ちる全然落ちそうちょっと頑張り
ますどうでしょうだいぶ綺麗になったので
はないでしょう
[音楽]
か
よしよっしゃなんかここら辺を汚れという
より
石のなんか色みたいになっててどうしよう
もない場所かもしれないですだいぶ綺麗に
なったのではないでしょう
かはいというわけで高圧水上機でいろんな
場所を掃除してみましたこれねあの
めっちゃ楽そうに見えますけど出力高い
水圧出す時ってめっちゃ水が細くてペンで
書いてるみたいな0.5mmのシャーペン
でなんか全部塗りつぶしてるみたいな感覚
で当てなきゃいけなくてめっちゃ大変なん
ですよなかなか全ての場所を完璧に綺麗に
することはできなかったんですけどもなん
となく自分が今綺麗にしたい場所はね綺麗
にできたかなと思います細かい部分は人に
任せますすごいな威力強すぎてなんか石の
破片めっちゃついてるんです
[音楽]
よこれ大丈夫家壊したまである
ぞ壊したけど家の壁ちょっとぶっ壊れ
ちゃったんですけどもすごいね水の力って
水圧高かったらなんかワンチン10の威力
にもなるとも言われておりますそんだけね
水ってすごいんですよ皆さんといて
くださいだけどいいですね普段掃除しない
場所綺麗にできるなちょっとねテンション
上がりましたまだ機会があったらちょっと
やってみたいと思います
[音楽]
じん